hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry ENCOM and today we're going to
continue our pharmacology series by
talking about the medication heparin and
after you get done watching this youtube
video don't forget to access the free
quiz that will test you on this
medication so let's get started
as we've been studying these medications
in this series we have been remembering
the word nurse because this helps us
remember those important questions we
need to ask ourselves while studying
these medications so we're dealing with
heparin and sometimes you may see it
written as unfractionated heparin so the
first thing we want to ask yourself is
what name what family name does this
drug fall into because that's going to
tell us how this drug works well heparin
is part of the in direct thrombin
inhibitor family so it indirectly
inhibits thrombin because it does this
this makes this drug an anticoagulant
which is going to alter the clotting
process now how does heparin do this
well it affects the intrinsic pathway of
coagulation and this pathway is
activated when there is internal trauma
to the vascular system compared to the
extrinsic pathway which is activated
when there's external trauma which is
how warfarin / coumadin really worked it
affected the extrinsic pathway but
heparin affects the intrinsic pathway
now how it specifically does this is
that heparin will bind with a naturally
occurring substance in the body and when
it does this it enhances the activity of
this substance which we're talking about
antithrombin 3 and antithrombin 3
inhibits the enzymes that will play a
role in the clotting process and it's
specifically going to prevent the
activation of thrombin and if we prevent
the activation of thrombin we're going
to alter claudine because we're going to
prevent the conversion of fibrinogen to
fibrin which is going to result in
slower clotting times for our patient
and this will help prevent clots and if
they already have an existing clot
prevent that clot from getting
bigger and potentially breaking off and
going into circulation
now one thing heparin does not do is it
does not lysis or break up an existing
clot and when we're talking about clots
one thing we're talking about is like
venous thromboembolism VTES and a lot of
times we start out as small little clots
in the vessel and we refer to those as
deep vein thrombosis DVT and these clots
can grow and they can break off and they
can go into circulation when they do
this it becomes an embolism and these
clots can travel throughout the body and
cause a lot of problems you can go to
the lungs where we refer to that as like
a PE a pulmonary embolism or these clots
can go to the heart circulation where
the heart muscle is fed by those
arteries and can block the circulation
to the heart muscle and a myocardial
infarction can occur or these clots can
go up through the brain circulation
block blood flow to an area of the brain
and lead to a stroke so these clots can
be very dangerous now let's ask
ourselves what is heparin used for why
may our patient be on heparin well we've
already established heparins and
anticoagulant so it's going to be used
to prevent and treat blood clots and
patients now what kind of conditions may
a patient have that heparin can treat
well patients who have those VTES those
venous thromboembolism or a pulmonary
embolism stroke help prevent a stroke
where the clot can go and block the
blood flow to the brain for atrial
fibrillation
whenever patients have this their heart
really isn't empty and like it should
blood is pulling from those erratic
impulses in the heart and a clot can
form because anytime blood pulls
together clots can form and we want to
prevent like a clot being shot out of
the heart and leading to a stroke or in
certain cases of surgery like cardiac
surgery or some types of orthopedic
surgery like hip surgery where there's
an increased risk of clot development
next let's talk about the
responsibilities of the nurse for a
patient who is
on heparin so one thing you want to know
is how is heparin administered
well we can give it through an injection
via the fatty sub-q tissue or the IV
route intravenously through a continuous
infusion so let's talk about the
continuous IV route first whenever a
continuous heparin is ordered we will
hang a bag of it and it's referred to as
a heparin drip and we will titrate this
strip based on a protocol that has very
specific guidelines that will be based
on the patient's a PTT result and a PT T
stands for activated partial
thromboplastin time and that is what we
care about with heparin so remember that
and here in a moment I'm gonna go
in-depth about this result
so based on this result either we will
increase the drip give the patient a
bolus or we will turn the drip off for
an hour decrease the rate or there'll be
no change to the drip until the next a
PTT result and the whole reason we're
doing that is because we're trying to
get this patient within this therapeutic
range so we can prevent blood clots so
it has to be therapeutic for it to
actually work because we can cause them
too much bleeding or we can actually
cause them in where it's not working at
all and they'll get blood clots
so with this heparin drip this result
will be drawled every like four to six
hours I've mainly seen at six hours it
depends on your hospital protocol and
before you start heparin heparin is a
weight based drug so you need to have an
accurate current weight on that patient
so proper dosing can be administered so
prior to giving this make sure you have
an accurate weight so now let's talk
about that activated partial
thromboplastin time that a PTT so what
is the difference between a PTT vs. and
a PTT well they both measure the same
thing but the a PTT has an activator
added to it to speed up the clotting
time hence why it has that a in front
so it's going to have a little bit more
of a narrow range than your PTT but they
measure the same thing so I wanted to
quickly go over that because you may see
those use interchangeably and I wanted
you to know the difference
so these lab results they measure those
intrinsic and common pathways of the
coagulation so it's going to tell us how
long those coagulation factors are
working to form a clot and remember
whenever we have a patient on heparin we
want it to fall within a certain
therapeutic range so we can prevent
blood clots but we don't cause them to
excessively bleed so these results are
measured in seconds now what is a normal
a PTT a normal one is about 30 to 40
seconds depending on the lab that's an
approximate range so in order for a
patient to be therapeutic we want them
to have a reading of 1.5 to 2.5 times
the normal range of what this normal
should be so anywhere between 60 to 80
seconds they would be therapeutic so
let's look at that range if they're a
PTT was less than 60 what would that
mean that would mean that they're not
therapeutics so we may with their drip
have to possibly give them a bolus or
increase their rate because they're not
where we want them and they could
develop blood clots now if they were
higher on the higher spectrum like
greater than 80 were that risk for
bleeding because they're clotting time
is really pro wrong so we may according
to protocol have to turn them drip off
for an hour or decrease their Rea
so with heparin one thing I really want
you to remember is about this a PTT it
needs to be 1.5 to 2.5 times the normal
range for that patient to be therapeutic
now let's look at some more
responsibilities especially with the
injectable heparin through the sub-q
tissue as a nurse we want to know where
how to get it so remember these points
we want to of course an insert in the
fatty tissue in the abdomen but we want
to stay at least two inches away from
the belly button and one inch away from
scars because if you inject there it's
not really going to absorb because you
have that scar tissue also rotate sites
so look in the chart where did the
previous nurse administer it ask the
patient and always go on the opposite
side and whenever you give it don't
massage or a spray or rub the injection
side another thing we want to do is
monitor for bleeding any type of
patients on any anticoagulant they're at
risk for bleeding and it's usually going
to be in the most subtle places so you
want to look after urine are they losing
blood in their urine does it look yellow
or does it look like a pinkish reddish
tint to it that could indicate hematuria
in how does their stool look is it dark
and tari
that could be blood that's referred to
as Malena how does it look around their
gums do they have using of blood that
can indicate we have some bleeding
issues and are they vomiting if so what
does it look like does it look like
coffee ground emesis that could indicate
blood and how does their vital signs
look is their heart rate really high and
their blood pressure low we talked about
this with our hypovolemic shock when a
patient can Hamrick that can indicate
that or are they all of a sudden
complaining of the severe sudden
headache to mean that we have some brain
bleeding in our brain and look at their
labs have they haven't had a significant
drop in their hemoglobin hematocrit
level that's looking at our red blood
cells and how do their platelets look do
they have a drop in their platelets
which can indicate heparin induced
thrombocytopenia so we want to be
watching out for those things as well
now let's quickly talk about this
heparin induced thrombocytopenia because
it can happen to your patient who is on
heparin and you want to be on the
lookout for it so what is it well it's
when
antibodies are created against the
heparin because it is bind with platelet
factor 4 so when the heparin and
platelet factor 4 have fine these
antibodies are created and they will go
and attach to this complex once it
attaches to this complex it will
activate the platelets whenever that
happens you're gonna have problems
you're gonna have small clots to form
and it's going to deplete our platelet
count hence thrombocytopenia so that is
really why we want to be looking at that
CBC those platelets and see if they've
dropped drastically because if they have
patient could be going into this some
other things you want to be looking out
for other than that low platelet count
is look do they have any worsening or
new clots that are developing and
depending on where that clot is we'll
just Herrmann the sign and symptom for
instance if they're gonna get a new DVT
it can be a warm harden swollen area
they have in the lungs it can be a chest
pain shortness of breath the heart
things like that even going to the brain
they can have mental status changes so
you want to be always assessing those
areas now how about if this develops
what happens well as a nurse you can
expect the heparin drip to be
discontinued it will be documented in
the patient's health history that they
have this and to never put them on
heparin again and they can be started on
another anticoagulant the family of the
direct thrombin inhibitors like al
Gatchaman or by valor Rudin which is
angio Mac's to help with their
anticoagulation some other things you
want to remember what the responsibility
part of heparin is the antidote always
remember the antidotes for these
medications in the antidote for heparin
is protamine sulfate and whenever you
give medications always avoid the I M
route because these patients are at risk
for bleeding it takes them a while to
clot so we want to avoid i M injections
and when drawing blood we want to make
sure that we hold firm direct pressure
after drawing the blood because they can
bleed for a while and we want to prevent
a hematoma from forming and also teach
the patient about that as well
especially the
get injure they'll need to hold pressure
for a while this medication can be used
during pregnancy warfarin could not be
used during pregnancy and speaking of
warfarin this medication heparin can be
used as a bridge while a patient is
being switched warfarin because warfarin
takes about three to five days for the
patient to become therapeutic where the
INR is between two to three so they'll
be on heparin during that bridging time
then the heparin will be discontinued
because you know heparin has a short
half-life now let's talk about some
side-effects other than they can have
the excessive bleeding and the heparin
induced thrombocytopenia you want to
watch out for osteoporosis this can
occur in patients who take heparin long
term and in high doses because it can
stimulate the osteoclast activity and
inhibit osteoblast activity which will
alter the strength of the bone so watch
for bone fractures things like that and
other side effects could be hair loss
and rashes and lastly the education
pieces for the patient taking heparin
you'll want to teach them how to monitor
for signs and symptoms of that excessive
bleeding like looking in the urine the
stool the gums if they vomit what does
it look like things like that that they
would need to report to their doctor
also using a soft bristle toothbrush so
they don't cut the gums and cause it to
bleed and electric razors rather than
the straight razors because they may cut
themselves avoiding contact sports that
they can become injured have some type
of trauma that because they're
susceptible to bleeding that they could
really have a major injury also avoiding
taking aspirin any type of NSAIDs or
over-the-counter health vitamins because
this can interfere with heparin and
increase bleeding and always talk to
your healthcare provider before taking
any new medications and how to
administer the sub-q heparin you'll want
to demonstrate to the patient show them
make them demonstrate back to you to
make sure that they're doing it right
and to always let other health care
providers know that they're taking
heparin especially prior to any type of
invasive procedure okay so that wraps up
this review over heparin thank you so
much for watching don't forget to take
the free quiz and to subscribe to our
channel for more videos